we had the sound of tears the sound of
the painful swallowing of tears and the
sound of silence it's time for roses and
Rose a hi you guys i'm lauren zima
that was part one of the finale of
Golden Underwood season of The Bachelor
everybody oh my gosh you guys what an
episode we had Colton's shaking and
crying we had Colton breaking up with
two people hurt somebody else
I can't be alone with two people we had
the bachelor without a woman in his life
for the first time in the history of the
show that's the first time in bachelor
history that that is happened I love
this episode why did you guys think let
me know and let's get in to it because
Colton got out of it with multiple
people okay so of course we're gonna get
the finale episode mixed in with live
portions and interviews with the cast
offs from Chris Harrison Chris calls the
fence jump the most shocking moment in
bachelor history bachelor history
history do we agree I don't know if I'd
call it the most shocking moment
especially because it was in the teaser
from the very beginning of the season so
we always knew if the season was leading
up to it so I wasn't guys like shocked
by it you think then we get the fence
jump and the aftermath and I have a lot
of questions about the editing of the
fence jump and the aftermath now did we
add in some vents creaking sounds
Colten that seemed louder than it was
before we're out in the middle of
nowhere and what's Chris actually on the
phone look at that phone we're gonna
have to great
there was no there's the brightness on
the phone who's he talking to buddy it
wasn't me you guys some of these said
that I'm Twitter it wasn't okay so we
are looking for Colton like it is the
Bourne Identity ultimatum next chapter :
under what is Jason Bourne hair you know
where is he we're in the brush we've got
night vision we have lots of cars and
then we find him pretty quickly and
Colton is not o.k no do not drink every
time somebody asks cold if he's okay
this episode golden in fact is done and
Colton is crying and do not drink every
time somebody cries this episode mmm so
I got a big glass and I put ice in it so
that it would last long and Colton says
something so painful to Chris he says
I've been through enough
but knowing I'm man enough for a long
time every time he's dumped it is a
reminder that he's not enough but it
just makes him stronger just makes me
stronger
that was hard and I was cheering for
Colton in that moment were you guys was
that painful don't drink every time
somebody just says something so painful
hmm wasn't it it was gonna weigh were
like you feel bad saying it's good
because it's so bad but it's bad that
it's good because looks so painful and
sad that's how bad it is it's so bad
that it's sad and you feel bad saying
it's good but it is good and you feel
that it's good because you're a fan of
the show so we're gonna see the episode
and we're gonna cut back to the audience
and there's gonna be so much silence oh
when we come back and it is so good do
not drink every time there are styles in
this episode
just the sound of ice and a glass of
wine that's all I mean this one okay
really so seemingly the next morning
after the fence jump chris is reunited
with Colton and Chris get a haircut even
I couldn't tell I get some questions
about the editing but whatever Chris got
to give him credit asks the tough
question what if the bottom line is
she's just not that into you
Wow cheers to Chris for asking the tough
questions
oh cool however it was so confident the
Cassie
is into him in fact he says thanks she
loves me do you guys agree I feel like I
have a pretty good gut instinct does
Cassie love Colton I'm not sure I agree
I admire Colton's confidence I don't
know where it came from just hours ago
he was crushed in a street in Portugal
saying that you know he'd no one ever
loves him back I'm confused
where do you guys think he was getting
that confidence anyway last night
Cassie won't wait for me Cole is then
being forced to narrate his own pain for
us and just relive the Cassie breakup
and I just kept thinking oh my god now
is the time for a vlog why aren't we
getting a vlog now would have been the
moment talked directly to the phone
you're in pain this is very personal
are you kidding me
[Applause]
so now we have break up number one
golden is going to break up with
Taoiseach and Wow Wow Wow okay
ten seconds into the break-up Taoiseach
is the one comforting Colton and I just
want to say cheers to Taoiseach for a
bunch of things during this breakup you
guys what did you think about Taoiseach
he handled the break-up I applaud her I
think she kind of saw it coming you know
she had that little smile and she said
and that was that her drowned bachelor
nation it said it all
I admire Colton's honesty cheers to him
he just straight-up told ketchup I love
Kathy and tisha is still holding hands
with him cheers to Taoiseach and oh my
god again don't drink every time there's
silence
[Applause]
[Music]
how long has it been since tisha has
said any words and then tatius words are
can we talk without all the cameras what
a season it has been everybody for
breaking down the fourth wall right I
mean we saw : jump the fence and we saw
the producers and now Taoiseach wants to
go where there are no cameras again you
guys do know you're on a reality show
though right I mean unlike Colton when
he jumped the fence
they left the mics on this time so he
heard everything and oh my god we have
had the sound of silence well this is
the sound of just painful painful
conversation so they go behind closed
doors and the camera guy seems to like
sit his camera down on a curb or
something and it's not a great angle but
you know he's probably tired he was out
all night with the fence jump that's
what I was thinking this man had to sit
down and never have I been more
captivated by a door we were just
watching through the door and we were
hearing everything and it was so painful
and do not drink every time tation is
comforting cool and then tisha finally
breaks a drink
don't cry into your wine or do that's
dark it's okay to get tired sometimes
you might get started I'm getting weird
okay Aisha says she doesn't want to go
through this and I like I said don't
drink every time something is just so
painful what did you guys think she
meant by that I understood it to mean
that she knew that they should break up
she knew Colton wasn't into her but she
just didn't want to go through the
process of a breakup oh so painful so
painful grieving the loss of whatever
this skydiving bungee jumping sitting on
the edge of a cliff in relationship was
okay breakup you know they hug and it's
chase your grabs their straw purse and
not really any luggage don't know where
luggage was and okay and
to shag to comfort herself
Oh God we finally saw that moment again
cheers - cheers to you Taoiseach you
worked hard this episode and you know
when tisha didn't work hard though is
back in the studio again we have silence
and by the way Taoiseach looked great
cheers to tation for looking great but
she was not there in the studio to work
hard she had done all her work I think
she was overcome and she didn't have
much to say and so I don't know much to
say about Colton tatius conversation I
don't really even remember it I just
remember how great taste she looked she
wasn't super emotional when Chris asked
her if she was in love with Colton still
I almost got the vibe that like she made
me thought she was never in love with
Colton what do you guys think was tisha
ever in love with Colton that was the
vibe I got she took a long silent pause
when he said you loved this guy you
really did love this guy we had a lot
again silence is golden or silences
darkness
but anyway uh what I do have something
to say about his Colton's hair
Wow Wow Wow the tie was better than
women tell all wasn't it
which hair did you like better women
tell all hair or live finale hair
oh cool and if Colton knew what he
wanted and I'm just gonna let him he was
on this journey for that bottom line I
just want to cheers to Taoiseach because
she said I know that I deserve a lot and
a good amazing person in my life yes you
do Queen we all do okay then the Hannah
beep no G okay let's all be honest
that's where we were with the energy she
was very forgettable and honestly we had
not seen her in hours of television she
wasn't even on the episode last week I
was just happy to see her alive again
journaling sitting on the world's
tiniest couch doing whatever she's been
doing for all this time I feel like
Hannah's been like in a cave and she's
emerging from a cave and she's like what
our cell phones beep he was cell phones
I don't know I've been journaling anyway
glad to see that Hanna Jie is alive and
well and then she's gonna get broken up
with oh my gosh I want to cheers to
Colton because he did not come in like
Cassie did with him he came in he was
like I have to talk to you you didn't
come in all smiley and kissy he laid it
out right away and Anna
unfortunately says my stomach's gonna be
Charlie
and little does she knows that's the
least of her worries hardest times you
get through all that okay so don't drink
during every awkward swallowing painful
sound so that was like swallowing of
emotion here's where Colton has some big
missteps this episode guys and I
couldn't feel a ton of sympathy from him
did you feel bad for Colton during the
Hannah G breakup I just felt like he was
saying things to her like she has been
his rock and she's Silverman and this
whole time he thought it was going to be
her don't you say that to Hanna G look
all we know is that she can beatbox yes
but that doesn't mean she's emotionless
he did tell her straight up I loved
Cassie and she seemed totally shocked
and blindsided what does it mean for you
guys for someone to tell you that you
remind them of home I don't even know
what that means does that mean Colton
loved Hannah I don't know what that
means I've never said that to someone
much like I've never told someone I'm
falling in love with them it's weird if
Hannah reminds Cole of home I don't know
I guess he's ready to move away
I guess he's ready for his next chapter
I guess he's very first first apartment
and he's gonna rent us I'm gonna be
great but it's gonna have the most basic
city his name it's a nice studio I don't
know he's just ready to move on he's
ready to you know house the sticks
- um credit card and start building up
his credits or he's ready to get a car
he wants to get his own insurance he's
not gonna his own health insurance toys
26 cousins parents all the choices have
a full-time job but he's ready to take a
first step
tripping an adult anyway everybody be an
adult I'm sweating okay
so cool in the sighs things like helped
him through so much wow what a
compliment during a breakup thanks but
no thanks Colton not for our queen
Hannah gee first she seems like she's in
shock then it's sinking in and she's
crying and kolnas crying is crying and
shaking
let him blog anyway so coolin is then
getting all upset and he's like telling
hannah this is why it's so hard and I'm
saying goodbye to somebody who loves me
what the f am i doing what the f are you
doing cold and I do think you should be
breaking up with Hanna because you
clearly seem to be into Cassidy but what
I don't think you should be doing is
telling Hanna that you're confused about
what you're doing don't tell her you're
second guessing this be firm be strong
vlog maybe should have filmed the
breakup on a blog and just texted it to
her she has never phone she only has her
journal anyway cool the same thing I
don't want to lose you I don't know if
I'm making the right decision Shh back
to the live show oh he looks good to
tayshon Hannah both looking great
cheers said that yes why did I do this
cheers to them yes and do not drink for
every sniffle during this breakup
and then Hannity is gonna leave and why
can't someone give her a coat she looks
cold but whatever she says she doesn't
want to talk about it I don't wanna talk
about anything and she's gone and here's
the thing
Hannah was somebody who I thought was
gonna come to the live finale and not
much to saying that Taoiseach was gonna
have a time to say no no no the tables
have turned
Hannah G is the goddess we didn't know
we needed G is for goddess I love her
yes energy what a turn we took on this
life Benally were you guys surprised
about how vocal Hannah G was I was
forget silence it's time to talk your
Hannah GE Hannah G is saying things like
she doesn't even know what she's gonna
say on this stage I just want to follow
my heart and whatever my heart says I
should ask and go with I'm gonna do it
oh she's gone rogue and she is saying
that she wants to be able to sleep
better at night and finally live in the
present good she has been living in the
silence and we've all been in the
silence but now that silence is broken
Hannah Jeanne is here to give words G is
for go manage ego
I've losing it okay so Hannah G tells
Colton how love works I know what love
is and it has to be a two-way street and
I feel like I deserve somebody who loves
me just as much as I love them obviously
that's how it works
yes shears do you Hanna G and she says
to Colton that what Kathy did to you was
exactly what you did to me shears day
Anna G I loved how she laid her out on
the table she even said what might have
been the most bachelor II breakup II
think I've ever heard she said that she
was so blindsided because she's so
thought it was gonna be them the whole
time just as cold and said he thought I
was gonna be here but she considered
that Colton would chase her I I thought
that you were gonna chase me as crazy as
that sounds like and she told a producer
to make sure that her hair looks good if
he came after
iconic iconic and you know what it would
have looked good and she looked great
anyway so has said she is stronger than
she knew showed me home strong I am
and again Hannah went from a beatboxing
blase blonde from Alabama to a goddess
of feminism and independence and sooth
sing and someone who I would follow to
the ends of the earth G is for goddess
Hanna G I adore thee I love the energy
right now there are no more women
important why alright so we wrap up the
show by Chris Harrison noting that this
is the first time in bachelor history
that the bachelor is no women and it's
like it's true
colton broke up a t-shirt : broke up
with energy and we ended all that
Colton's knock-knock-knocking on Cassie
used or didn't know she was still in
Portugal that was the price anyone else
I thought you'd be stopped but you've
out her dad in that van I don't know
some people pointed out on Twitter that
Colton's hair looks like Cassie's dad's
hair so you guys that is part one of
cold Underwood's live finale ending of
the season 23 of the virgin bachelor
most dramatic moment ever fence jumping
bachelor season love you guys so much
this season of The Bachelor we must of
course have another episode of on the
journey with JC here he is ready to sit
on the couch what did you think of Hanna
Jia she really handled it well I mean
she handled it with class a lot of Becca
vibes cool friends okay Hanna stands for
handling it well we applaud you Hanna ji
we applaud you a star is born
[Music]
[Music]